على ربوه مخضره في مقدمه جبال الريف مدينه
صغيره تعرف بوزان في الشمال الغربي للمغرب
مناخ المدينه البارد شتاء يدفع رجال وزان
لارتداء جلباب ينسب اسمه للمدينه وهو
متورث عن الاباء في مجال صغيره تنتج
النساء خيوط هذا اللباس الرجالي وبالات
تقليديه تبدا عمليه غزل صوف الاغنام
الدم كان ما يمكن تعجبني
كتعجبني فيها كان خدموها بيها مهم خدامين
على وليداتنا بها كانترزقوا بالله بها
رقيه تحول الصوف الى كتل من الخيوط
باستعمال اله الناعوره
يسبح صوتها بالغناء الجبلي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حماس لم يفطر منذ 50 عاما يعمل بكدا
الاخوان
دوامه يوم كامل على اله المرمه يثمر قطعه
قماش واحده تسمى الوزانيه
كليه
محلي يعني تراث وطني
على مقاسه ومواقبه لتطورات الحاصله ابدع
صناع التقليديون تصاميم عصريه موجهه
للشباب بالخصوص
المدينه فيتجهون لاقدم سوق شعبيه
من الاثواب الصوفيه الخالصه بين ان فرحه
الاقبال على الجلباب تقابلها هواجس
الحرفيين
قطاعا تقليديا بامتياز
ونتمنى ان نتضارك هذا المورود تاريخي حتى
لا يخرج عن السياقه ويذهب كبير من الحرف
وبالاضافه لاشهر الشتاء تنتعش تجاره
الجلباب ايضا خلال المناسبات الدينيه كما
هو الحال في بقيه مناطق المغرب
من اصواف الغنم يحاك الجلباب الوزاني
ليمنح لابسه الدفعه ويقيه برد الشتاء في
ظل درجات حراره منخفضه اما وزان فقد
اكسبها الجلباب صيطا تجاوز حدود لها
الجزيره التي توزع